i
[Música]
ah
en el año se empiezan a sentir los
efectos de la llegada de joe biden a la
presidencia de los estados unidos en los
últimos días ha ido bajando el precio
del dólar respecto a real la moneda
local que era algo que esperaba no
solamente el gobierno sino la mayoría de
los iraníes que ven con esperanza esa
posibilidad de que yo y bailén regrese
al acuerdo nuclear del cual se había
retirado a eeuu por orden de donald
trump en el 2018 impuso unas fuertes y
más sanciones económicas contra el país
e irán exige a eeuu que desmonte todas
estas sanciones económicas y a cambio
promete regresar su programa nuclear en
el punto en el que estaba en el 2018
cuando eeuu se retiró del acuerdo pero
esto no será fácil y todos y bailén
deciden regresar al acuerdo nuclear los
expertos aseguran de que habrá que crear
un cronograma en el cual puntualmente
ambos países tanto eeuu como irán
vayan cumpliendo sus compromisos hasta
llegar al mismo punto donde está acaban
en el 2018
[Música]
rusia entro en el nuevo año pendiente de
la llegada de joe biden a la casa blanca
el kremlin se ha preparado para un
gobierno norteamericano de nuevo más
interesado en rusia y más dispuesto a
cooperar con antiguas repúblicas
soviéticas pero después de los
disturbios de este mes en washington
moscú no quiere más lecciones sobre
democracia norteamericana baiden no es
una novedad a la que moscú pueda dar un
voto de confianza fue de hecho uno de
los motores de la política exterior de
barack obama sobre todo en ucrania el
asunto por el que más se degradó la
relación entre ambos países
moscú siente que eeuu no quiere ver a
rusia como un socio con igualdad de
derechos pero combaten el enfoque en
política exterior será más tradicional
menos estimulante en principio para
moscú pero al mismo tiempo más
previsible al fin y al cabo el mandato
de trump ha decepcionado bastante en el
crimen
[Música]
hace unos pocos días el presidente de
venezuela nicolás maduro dijo que su
gobierno no está esperando nada del
presidente electo de eeuu joe biden y
llamó sus seguidores a trabajar en unión
nacional y encontrar sus propios caminos
sin embargo desde que se conoció que va
a ir en sustituir a donald trump el
mandatario venezolano ha dicho
públicamente que espera abrir vías de
comunicación y diálogo con el maduro
lleva cuatro años de duros
enfrentamientos con el gobierno de trump
además washington ha impuesto una
avalancha de sanciones contra la nación
sudamericana que incluye un embargo
petrolero la vicepresidenta del tse
rodríguez también anunció recientemente
que esperan que la nueva administración
norteamericana tenga atisbos de decencia
cumpla con el derecho internacional y
establezca canales diplomáticos de
diálogo respetuoso bailén ya he dicho
que el mandatario venezolano es
simplemente un dictador no obstante
analistas creen que será más moderado y
abogará por una mediación internacional
para una gradual transición hacia un
nuevo gobierno venezolano
[Música]